I can now officially say that I've held
an Oscar on this page
congratulations Oscar's not so wait now
I winged the seemingly impossible task
of sound editors is to immerse the
viewer in a world they and we have
likely never heard firsthand these years
nominees have vividly brought to life
first world war trenches the Manson
Ranch in the city of Gotham the LeMans
racetrack and even a galaxy far far away
and yet so close here are the nominees
for achievement in sound editing Ford
versus Ferrari
Donald Sylvester Joker Alan Robert
Murray 1917
Oliver tarney and Rachel tape once upon
a time in Hollywood wily statement Star
Wars the rise of Skywalker Matthew wood
and David a port and the Oscar goes to
[Applause]
Donnell Sylvester
[Applause]
Ford versus Ferraris is a marriage of
sound and picture so while I really want
to thank my fantastic sound team I also
want to include the picture team and the
mixers in fact Ford yep Ford versus
Ferrari is probably the last film ever
made by 20th Century Fox so I want to
thank I want to thank Aaron downing and
Ted Galliano and Emma watts but the real
support comes from Holmes I want to
thank my wonderful wife of 34 years who
gave up her editing career for me to
pursue my career but she raised our kids
and she did a great job because neither
one of them are politicians but the real
reason I'm standing here is of James
Mangold he is the reason I'm here he
should have been nominated for Best
Director so if I could I'd break this
statue off and give him the head so you
could put it in the jar Jim Thank You
Academy
[Applause]